Hey guys we're back.
It's the next day and our silicone has
fully cured from our last experiment
where we took a vacuum chamber
and sucked all the air bubbles out of the silicone first
The idea being, that now our pokeball molds should be completely bubble free.
So now we get to see if that is really the case.
Now you've already seen me rip these off and cut them open in a previous video
So I'm not gonna spend a lot of time doing that here
Lets just dive right in and get it done.
Cool guys. so we got our silicone molds out of the casings
And if you look down here, where the clay was, you can see it makes a really cool cavity.
And so now, when we pour molten Aluminum, Wax or even gummy Syrup
It's gonna have a reservoir to draw from as it cools and shrinks
I did notice on this one however, the clay was pushed up a little bit too high into the ball and that creates a bit of a problem
because now the ball is exposed
that means the inside of this ball mold isn't fully complete
The cool thing about silicone is: even though it's cured we can add more and it will fuse in and make one solid chunk of silicone.
So even though we messed up here and didn't completely cover the ball
We can just mix up a little bit more, pour that in
and when it sets, it should be perfect
The only problem is, we only need one tablespoon of silicone
and i've got 5 gallons of the stuff
This looks like white frosting, it's really cool
Now we're not gonna need a lot of silicone, so i just mixed up about 100 grams worth here
and honestly we're probably gonna waste more than we actually use
But when you're dealing with quantities this small there's not much else we can do
Now I am gonna stick this in the vacuum chamber as well
and one interesting thing about this vacuum chamber is that if you look at this gauge
it's still suctioned up
I set this last night and sucked it down to about 25 inches of mercury
and interestingly enough
over the entire night, it's only slipped down to about 23
and the vacuum pump is not running, it's just maintaining vaccum pressure with these valves here
so i thought that was pretty cool and it means our proto-putty seal is working as intended
Sweet! Thats the stuff right there. Just made it to the lip of that cup
and now the bubbles are being extracted. So we just need that to settle down and then it should be good to pour.
See, that suctions on pretty good
And our glass jar is not exploding, that's always a plus. :)
And now if we just drizzle this straight over this pokeball until the bottom is covered
we should be in business.
alright, let's call that good!
(tries to pull it up) It's stuck. (laughs)
This bottom is actually so smooth
that if I slam it down on a hard surface
It creates a suction cup that's actually
Very difficult to get back off
(arrrrrrrrr) WOW!
Impressive  hehehehe
Maybe we could use silicone to make our own suction cups
Now before we cut this thing open
you guys tell me in the comments... "Do you think
we made a mold that came out bubble free?"
I'm a little bit nervous and a little bit excited to find out
because i have no idea
There we go... another successful extraction
so, cool!
now another little tweak I made to these pokeballs before I stuck them in the silicone
I took a bead of hot glue and wrapped it around the inside
to prevent the silicone from seeping in
It looked like it actually work out pretty well that time
we don't have these things loaded up with silicone
so yay!
alright so the moment of truth how does it look
on the inside? Lets take a peak
ohh yeah
that is actually looking really good
I see nothing but smooth silicone
no bubbles this time
that's a dramatic difference from our last mold
do you remember our last one was  pocked with bubbles everywhere
and this one completly smooth
that is very encouraging I like that
yeah that looks.. just about perfect
all we have to do now is trim up some of the
flaps here, you can see where it leaked into the balls a little bit
but if we can trim those up
i think were going to have ourselves a pretty dang nice pokeball mold
(sings) Like a surgeon
so cool guys so our mold is looking awesome
im really excited to see how our wax castings
is going to turn out
but before we cast the wax
there are a few suggestions from my friend Nate
about how to make this work little bit better. First of all,
maybe we should put it in the microwave for
about 3 minutes to warm the silicone up
Second of all when we pour the wax in here let's start off with a little bit and rotate the mold around
so it coats the inner walls of the mould first
and after we fill this thing up with wax
let's throw it in a vacuum chamber for a couple of minutes so see
if there's any air in molten wax
If we follow all those suggestions
perfectly I'm fairly confident
we're going to end up with a perfect wax Pokeball.
So our mold just came out of the microwave
It's nice and toasty warm right now
and our wax is completely molten
So, let's pour the WAX!
Beauuutiful.... alright, gonna stop there for just a second.
So what I'm doing now is I'm just rotating this gently
to put a nice wax coating on the inner walls of the mold.
The idea being that that will fill in any gaps and prevent any air bubbles.
Let's pour the rest.
Ok now at this point I'm just going to stop for a second
and put this thing in the vacuum chamber to see if there are any air bubbles in there that we can suck out first.
Oh I see some bubbles rising there!
Interesting!
Wow that's incredible!
So I'm not really sure where those bubbles are coming from whether they're
leaking through the cracks in the side of the silicon mold
or these are actually bubble that were in the wax itself
but in either case I'm feeling  a lot more confident now that we have run them through a cycle in the vacuum chamber
alright let's release the pressure
[ Air hissing back into vacuum chamber ]
super cool
beauteous
there's our wax... hopefully bubble free
it's interesting it also looks like the wax has shrunk down a little bit
I wonder if that's because it's cooled in the vacuum?
but in either case we're going to top this thing off so it has a nice reservoir to draw from
there we go right to the very top and we'll see how much that actually shrinks down.